الانبعاثات الملوثه قد تسرع من انتشار
السيارات الكهربائيه في الولايات المتحده
هذا ما تطمح اليه الحكومه الامريكيه التي
ادخلت معايير اكثر صرامه بشان انبعاثات
السيارات وتتمثل المعايير في فرض قيود على
مصانع السيارات لخفض معدل الانبعاثات
الملوثه من السيارات فضلا عن تشجيعهم على
تصنيع السيارات الكهربائيه
وترمي الحكومه الامريكيه ايضا من خلال هذا
القرار للتقليل من استيراد النفط وخفض
نفقات سائقين السيارات على الوقود هذا
ووضعت حكومه الامريكيه هدفا جديدا يتمثل
في رفع مبيعات السيارات الكهربائيه الى
نسبه 67% من مجموعه سيارات المباعه في
البلاد بحلول عام 2032
وتعرف سوق السيارات الكهربائيه في
الولايات المتحده اقبالا ضعيفا حيث شكلت
فقط
5.8% من مجموع السيارات المباعه في البلاد
في عام 2022
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات